[Musik]
über baikonur weht die flagge mit hammer
und zirkel als sigmund jähn in den
weltraum startet es ist der 26
august 1978 beim wettlauf im all hat die
ddr die nase vorn
[Musik]
der propaganda kuh ist gelungen neun
tage verbringt jenen als gast auf der
raumstation saljut 6
der deutsche kosmonaut stammt aus dem
sächsischen vogtland und er passt
perfekt ins kader profil der
kommunistischen staatsführung sohn eines
einfachen arbeiters gelernter
buchdrucker und später jagdflieger mit
studium an einer sowjetischen militär
akademie ostberlin zelebriert seinen
kosmonauten als lebenden beweis für die
überlegenheit des sozialismus straßen
schulen und schiffe werden nach ihm
benannt jedes kind kennt ihn und yen
macht gute miene als kosmonaut zum
anfassen
schon zu lebzeiten setzt die ddr ihm ein
denkmal
erst fünf jahre später fliegt der erste
westdeutsche ins all
ulf merbold doch im geheimen haben
raumfahrer aus ost und west schon lange
vor dem fall der mauer kontakt man
trifft sich in jenes datsche im westen
ist je länger ein unbekannter ihn
berühmt
in seiner heimat morgenröthe rautenkranz
erinnert ein museum an den ddr flieger
kosmonauten der 30 jahre nach seinem
flug ins all
doch noch ein gesamtdeutscher volksheld
geworden ist